hey guys it's December nineteenth I'm
chastity covering for Jess we're gearing
up for our big 5 hour livestream
tomorrow counting down the top 5 games
of the year but first the news first up
a new Batman game is in the works from
the studio behind Arkham origins WB
games montreal was working on a Suicide
Squad game but according to a new report
it's been canceled sources told kotaku
about the cancellation and went on to
claim that the studio is now working on
a damian wayne batman game according to
kotaku three sources the Suicide Squad
game which was never officially
announced was abandoned earlier this
month following a long period of
turbulence at the studio the game was
set to be in the works for at least two
years like the movie the rumored game
would have start a team of antiheroes so
there might have been a co-op element as
for the damian wayne batman game kotaku
heard that it was planned to be revealed
at the start of december that didn't go
as planned and a reveal before the
holidays may not happen either next up
dishonor to gets a free update today
with a new game plus mode a
much-anticipated update is now available
for dishonored to adding a new game plus
mode this honor to take on the mode
allows you to replay the game using any
bone charm traits or runes you
discovered during your first playthrough
more importantly it also allows you to
access both Corvo and Emily's abilities
regardless of which character you choose
to play as which should open the door
for even more interesting combos this
free update comes just over a month
after the game was first released on
xbox one ps4 and PC a notably absent
feature the ability to go back and
replace specific levels won't arrive
until a new update comes in January that
will also provide custom difficulty
settings to tailor the experience to
your liking you can read the full patch
notes for today's update on gamespot com
and finally a huge Xbox Live sale is
going on this week and it has over 350
deals Microsoft will hold a countdown
sale on xbox live 4 2016 like it did
last year microsoft says this year's
sale is the biggest in the history of
the Xbox store featuring discounts on a
variety of xbox one and xbox 360 games
it begins on december twenty second and
offers 19 days of deals ending on
january 9th throughout the course of the
sale there will be discounts on hundreds
of games movies TV shows and more the
announcement video teases that there
will be up to 350 deals available
throughout the sale up from 200 plus
from last year Microsoft isn't revealing
a full lineup yet but has confirmed that
some of this year's biggest titles
including Final Fantasy 15 battlefield 1
and watch dogs too will be among those
discounted more than 40 backwards
compatible games are also going to be
marked down the reveal video for this
year's countdown sale shows games like
dead rising for Gears of War for Call of
Duty infinite warfare titanfall 2 Skyrim
special edition NBA 2k 17 and others
plus Microsoft will offer monthly xbox
live gold memberships for only one
dollar but this price is only four
people have never subscribed before
there will be daily and weekly offers so
keep checking back with gamespot for the
latest let me know what you think of
today's stories in the comments below
and don't forget that tomorrow we're
having a top five games of the year live
stream it's going on for five hours from
ten a.m. to three p.m. pacific time join
us for games prizes and a special guest
you will not want to miss it I'm
chastity and I'll see you tomorrow